greetings from Hollywood to our viewers
all around the world thank you for
watching thank you for having me it is a
great honor to be invited back for a
second time it's a great honor to be
here among so many talented women and
men congratulations to all of you you
made it we're at the Oscars some of you
will be going home tonight with an
Academy Award what could be better than
that
nothing right so if you want to mention
this year when you hear your name called
don't get up right away we don't want
another thing what happened last year
was unfortunate I've not told this story
in public because I wanted to save it
for tonight but here's what happened
this is true last year about a week
before the show the producers asked me
if I wanted to do some comedy with the
accountants and I said no I don't want
to do comedy with the accountants so
then the accountants
went ahead and did comedy on their own
and I have to hand it to them it was
hilarious but it won't happen again this
year the chairman of
PricewaterhouseCoopers said and I quote
our singular focus will be on the show
and delivering the correct envelopes
which is does make sense just out of
curiosity though what was your focus the
other 89 years
I'm hopeful the things will go smoothly
tonight we can't ruin this one this is a
special year this is a big one these are
the 90th Academy Awards this is history
happening right here Oscar is 90 years
old tonight which means he's probably at
home right now watching Fox News of
course no Oscar is here with us after
all the years after all the awards given
for achievements in show business
Oscar is still number one no question
about it Oscar is the most beloved and
respected man in Hollywood and there's a
very good reason why just look at him
keeps his hands where you can see them
never says a rude word and most
importantly no penis at all he is
literally a statue of limitations and
that's the kind of men we need more of
in this town here's how clueless
Hollywood is about women we made a movie
called what women want and it starred
Mel Gibson Chyna all you need to know
the Academy as you're no doubt aware
took action last year to expel Harvey
Weinstein from their ranks there were a
lot of great nominees but Harvey
deserved it the most and oh that's nice
that's very sweet so
I'm sure he'll appreciate that applause
the Academy kicked them out and after
they did I was curious so I looked it up
you know the only other person to be
expelled from the Academy ever was a
character actor named carmine Caretti
in 2004 he was kicked out for sharing
screeners carmine kerydin got the same
punishment as Harvey Weinstein for
giving his neighbor a copy of Seabiscuit
on VHS but what happened with Harvey and
what's happening all over was long
overdue we can't let bad behavior slide
anymore the world is watching us we need
to set an example and the truth is if we
are successful here if we can work
together to stop sexual harassment in
the workplace if we can do that women
will only have to deal with harassment
all the time at every other place they
go over the course of this evening I
hope you will listen to many brave and
outspoken supporters of movements like
me too and time's up and never again
because what they're doing is important
things are changing for the better
they're making sure of that it is
positive change this is a night for
positivity and our plan is to shine a
light on a group of outstanding and
inspiring films each and every one of
which got crushed by Black Panther this
weekend
[Applause]
the success of black panther is one of
many positive stories this year
especially for African Americans and Bob
Iger Black Panther and Wonder Woman are
massive hits which is almost miraculous
because I remember a time when the major
studios didn't believe a woman or a
minority could open a superhero movie
and the reason I remember that time is
because it was March of last year but
this year we have a lot to celebrate
ceilings have been shattered ceilings
and screenwriting we have our first ever
female nominee for cinematography so
many of tonight's nominees are making
history and in fact if you are a nominee
tonight who isn't making history shame
on you Greta Gerwig is the first woman
to be nominated for adult and that's
important only 11% of movies are
directed by women that is nuts we still
have a very long way to go in that
department and a very long way to go
when it comes to equal pay especially
when you look at what happened with Mark
Wahlberg and Michele Williams we all
know the story Mark Wahlberg was paid a
million and a half dollars to reshoot
his scenes while Michelle Williams for
her reshoots got per diem she was paid
$80 a day for the same thing
and what made it especially unfair is
that Mark and Michelle are represented
by the same agency and I've been mitt
this story really surprised me this one
shook me because if we can't trust
agents
who can we trust to his credit Mark
Wahlberg announced he would be donating
all 1.5 million dollars to The Times up
Legal Defense Fund
so I guess now the balls in your court
Michelle what are you going to do with
that 80 bucks
in the meantime triple congratulations
are in order for the kid from Comedy
Central Jordan Peele who
[Applause]
Jordan
the first person in 90 years to be
nominated for directing riding and best
pitcher for his debut film what did they
do it was none other than President
Trump called get out the best first
three-quarters of a movie this year
margot robbie had a great you know to
margot scored her first nomination for
her portrayal of Tonya Harding in hi
Tonya whose kneecaps did Tonya Harding
have to break to get this dream casting
because I mean that was if they made a
movie about my life best-case scenario
I'd be played by Jim Belushi another
exceptionally gifted young actor who is
nominated for the first time is Timothy
Shalom a are you having fun Timothy this
is a big Timothy is missing paw patrol
to be here tonight
don't worry rider and his team of pups
saved the day so Timothy is the star of
a small but powerful story called call
me by your name which did not make a lot
of money fact of the nine Best Picture
nominees only two of them made more than
a hundred million dollars but that's not
the point
we don't make films like call me by your
name for money we make them to upset
mike pence
[Applause]
eighty years and on the other end of the
abacus we have our oldest acting nominee
ever the Magnificent Christopher Plummer
this maybe this is not the place in
something I want to be asking how does
lin-manuel Miranda compared to the real
Alexander Hamilton
and once again right here in the front
row maybe the greatest actor of all time
Meryl Streep is here with us film career
started in 1977 the long that she ever
went without being nominated was from
1992 to 1995 was and that's only because
those were the years she was in prison
and that I think is amazing the most
nominated movie tonight a film that's up
for 13 Oscars is the shape of water
written and directed congratulations I'm
very happy for Emma you made a beautiful
movie and thanks sagir mo we will always
remember this year as the year men
screwed up so badly women started dating
fish okay before we start handing out
the awards some history because we're
going to do things a little bit
differently the first Oscar ceremony
lasted and this is true 15 minutes from
beginning to end and people still
complain but so if you do win an Oscar
tonight we want you to give a speech we
want you to say whatever you feel needs
to be said speak from the heart we want
passion we won't you have an opportunity
in a platform to remind millions of
people about important things like equal
rights and equal treatment if you want
to encourage others to join the amazing
students at parkland at their March on
the 24th through that
[Applause]
favorite feature do that or maybe you
just want to thank your parents and tell
your kids to go to sleep what you say is
entirely up to you you don't have to
change the world do whatever you want
but with that said this is a really long
show so here's what we're gonna do not
saying you shouldn't give a long speech
but whoever gives the shortest speech
tonight will go home with Johnny tell
them what they'll win
the number one choice for watercraft
enthusiasts retail price 17 $9.99 back
to you Jimmy Thank You Helen thank you
to Helen Mirren not included so there
you go why waste precious time thanking
your mom when you could be taking her
for the ride of her life on a brand-new
jetski this is not a joke I will be
timing you I have a stopwatch the moment
you are handed that Oscar the clock will
start ticking so get up here grab it and
go and in the unlikely event of a tie I
need to say the jet ski will be awarded
to Christopher Plummer so